I mentioned that any system design should be simple. And power of simplicity
is the key for adoption. So in this case, let's revisit the sequential program
for video analytics that I showed
you earlier. Converting the sequential program for
video analytics into a distributed program, using
the get put primitives, provided by PTS,
is fairly straightforward. What you do
is, you interpose between these computations,
that are there in the original pipeline, channels that are named entities
that can be used to hold the temporal evolution of output
from a particular computation. So in this case, camera capture is a thread,
and this capture computation captures images from
a camera with a certain periodicity. And
places it into a name channel called
frames, and so the frames channel abstraction is
going to contain the temporal evolution of
output produced by this capture computation. And
the detector can discover where this frame
channel is, connect to it, and get images
from this channel, process them and produce
blobs that characterize the objects that it
sees in any particular given frame. So
this is a temporal evolution of the detector's
output corresponding to the frames that it
sees. And the tracker takes these blobs.
And interesting blobs from that are the
objects that it is tracking and it produces
a temporal evolution of the location of objects that it sees and
places it in its output channel and a recognizer may then look at these
objects and consults. A database of known objects to see
whether any of those objects that are being continuously
captured, detected, and tracked, correspond to anything
that may indicate that there's an anomalous
situation. And those are the events that it
produces, and those events may trigger an
alarm. So basically, what, what I'm showing you
here is converting the sequential program for video analytics into a
distributed program using the channel abstraction and the get/put primitive
available in the PTS programming model. So the ovals
are the threads of the PTS abstraction and these rectangles
are the channels that are there between any two computational entities.